l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion en
2ème lecture de la proposition de loi
visant à mieux protéger et accompagner
les enfants victimes et covictimes de
violence intrafamiliale je donne la
parole tout de suite pour commencer à
madame la secrétaire d'État chargée de
l'enfance madame Charlotte
[Applaudissements]
cobel merci
monsieur
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Vice-Présidente de la commission des
lois madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés qui aujourd'hui
peut encore minimiser l'ampleur des
violences commises sur les enfants qui
peut encore aujourd'hui minimiser ou
nier l'impact sur le développement des
enfants sur leur vie d'enfant sur leur
futur vie d'adulte qui peut donc
aujourd'hui minimiser l'impérieuse
nécessité que nous avons d'agir ensemble
comme nous le faisons aujourd'hui je
Martelle à nouveau ces chiffres je suis
désolé je les martellerai tant qu'ils ne
diminueront pas 160000 160000 enfants
subissent chaque année des violence
sexuelle un enfant est donc victime
toutes les 3 minutes d'inceste de viol
ou d'agression sexuelle
143000 enfants au moins vivent dans un
foyer où une femme a déclaré être
victime de violence sur sonte conjoint
ou
ex-conjoint et puis évidemment un enfant
meurt tous les 5 jours sur les coups de
ses parents ce qui évidemment induit des
violences intrafamiliales avant face à
ces chiffres à cette
réalité
inacceptable le président de la
République a fait de l'enfance et de la
protection de l'enfance un des sujets
prioritaires du
quinena la protection des droits des
enfants commence évidemment par la
garant
de leur intégrité et de leur sécurité
physique mieux lutter contre les
violences faites à nos enfants doit être
pour nous tous le cœur de notre
engagement la première ministre a donc
structuré l'action résolue du
gouvernement en fixant une feuille de
route très claire suivie par un comité
interministériel de l'enfance pour
coordonner l'action de tous les
ministres
impliqués lundi 20 novembre prochain la
première ministre ira le 3ème comité
interministériel à l'enfance pour
notamment marquer une nouvelle étape de
notre mobilisation contre ce fléau nous
annoncerons des mesures complémentaires
dans un second plan de lutte contre les
violences faites aux enfants et nous
présenterons à cette occasion à partir
de notamment du travail effectué par la
civise et de ces recommandations très
utiles nos actions à
venir car depuis plus d'un an dans la
continuité de ce qui a été fait dans le
précédent quinena nous avons avancé nous
avons continué à travailler intensément
avec l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement pour mieux protéger les
enfants victime de violence c'est
notamment la création d'un office de
police dédié c'est notamment la
continuité du déploiement des uaped
c'est notamment le renforcement de la
formation professionnelle la mise en
place bientôt d'une plateforme de
soutien au professionnels c'est toutes
ces actions que nous continuons à à
mener c'est pourquoi à quelques jours de
la journée des droits des enfants je me
réjouis de voir arriver en deuxième
lecture devant votre assemblée la
proposition de loi visant à mieux
protéger les enfants victimes de
violence intrafamiliale porté avec
conviction par Madame Isabelle
Santiago ce texte madame la rapporteur
vient renforcer les outils de la justice
pour lutter plus efficacement contre ces
violences intrafamiliales et assurer une
protection complète des enfants qui en
sont
victimes votre proposition de loi
propose de renforcer les dispositifs
juridiques existants en suspendant
l'autorité parentale et ses attributs du
parent poursuivi pour agression et en
lui retirant de manière systématique en
cas de condamnation sauf décision
contraire spécialement
motivé le travail mené lors de l'examen
de ce texte a été appuyé par des
contributions décisives des membres de
la majorité au premier rang desquels
celle de la présidente de la délégation
au droits des enfants pine Goulet des
députés monsieur pouat dubrchira
monsieur balanan et de leurs collègues
madame poussier vincebac nous pouvons
dire aujourd'hui que ce texte soutenu
par le gouvernement fruit d'un travail
important avec la chancellerie et je
tiens ici à saluer le fort engagement
d'Éric Dupont Moretti enrichi par la
navette parlementaire approche désormais
de la maturité comme en témoigne le
petit nombre d'amendements soumis au
débat après une première navette je
souhaite revenir en quelques mots sur
les principales mesures et c'est sur les
équilibres qui les
soutendent l'article 1er étant au fait
d'agression sexuelle ou de crime commis
sur son enfant les principes et les
modalités de suspension de l'autorité
parentale et de ses attributs en cas de
poursuite par le ministère public de la
mise en examen par le juge d'instruction
ou de condamnation même non
définitive avec cet article la
suspension de plein droit de l'autorité
parentale et de ses attributs court
jusqu'à la décision du juge aux affaires
familiales qui peut être saisi par le
parent poursuivi ou jusqu'à la décision
de non lieu au jugement ou du jugement
ou de l'arrêt pénal ensuite cet article
prévoit également la suspension en cas
de condamnation même non définitive pour
des violences sur l'autre parent ayant
entraîné une incapacité totale de
travail supérieure à 8 jours lorsque
l'enfant a assister au fait je précise
que cette condition en vertu d'un décret
du gardess saut de fin 2021 est déjà
apprécié assez largement par les
autorités de poursuite qui procèdent
quasi systématiquement aux audition des
enfants en cas de violence conjugale
pour évaluer l'impact sur les mineurs et
en particulier lorsqu'ils ont été
témoins le gardessau une fois le texte
voté prendra une circulaire
d'application à destination des
procureurs afin de s'assurer que cette
nouvelle condition fixée dans la loi
soit évaluée de la manière la plus
systématique et la plus
large enfin dans cette nouvelle
hypothèse de retrait la suspension court
jusqu'à la décision du juge aux affffair
familial qui doit être saisi par l'un
des parents dans un délai de 6 mois à
compter de la condamnation à défaut de
saisine dans ces délais les droits du
parent condamné sont
rétablis vous l'aurez compris ce texte
est évidemment très efficace et je me
félicite que votre Commission ait
rétabli la version votée par l'Assemblée
nationale en première
lecture l'article 2 de la proposition de
loi élargit les modalités de retrait de
l'autorité parental et de ses attributs
si votre commission a décidé de
préserver pour partie la version du
Sénat elle a fait des ajouts qui
viennent parfaire le
dispositif pour appel la rédaction votée
par le Sénat en première lecture
modifier ce mécanisme de retrait de
l'autorité parentale ou de son exercice
afin de prévoir que lorsque le parent a
été condamné comme auteur co-auteur ou
complice d'une agression sexuelle
inessueuse commise sur son enfant ou
d'un crime commis sur son enfant ou sur
l'autre parent le juge pénal a
l'obligation de se prononcer sur le
retrait total de l'autorité parentale et
la décision de ne pas ordonner un tel
RET retrait doit être spécialement
motivé lorsque le parent a été condamné
comme auteur co-auteur ou complice d'un
délit commis sur l'enfant autre que
d'agression sexuelle incestueuse le juge
pénal a l'obligation de se prononcer sur
sur le retrait total ou partiel de
l'autorité parentale ou sur le retrait
de son exercice lorsque le parent a été
condamné comme auteur coauteur ou
complice d'un délit commis sur l'autre
parent ou comme coauteur ou complice
d'un crime ou d'un délit commis par par
son enfant le juge pénal a la
possibilité d'ordonner le retrait total
ou partiel de l'autorité parentale ou
son
exercice en deuxème lecture votre
commission a fait en sorte de renforcer
ce dispositif lorsque le parent a été
condamné comme auteur ou complice d'une
agression sexuelle inestueuse commise
sur son enfant ou d'un crime commis sur
son enfant ou sur l'autre parent le juge
pénal a maintenant l'obligation non plus
seulement de se prononcer mais
d'ordonner le retrait total ou partiel
de l'exercice de l'autorité parentale
sauf décision contraire spécialement
motivé ce n'est plus l'obligation de
statuer mais c'est l'obligation
d'ordonner sauf motivation spécialement
rédigé l'article 3 quant à lui vise à
coordonner le code pénal avec avec les
modifications introduites dans le Code
civil sur ce point la méthode adoptée
par les deux chambres est différente la
version qui est aujourd'hui soumise à
vos débats est celle modifiée par les
amendements de Madame la rapporteur et
de Monsieur le Député pouyaya adopté par
la commission ces derniers ont
principalement permis de rétablir
l'article 3 dans sa version adoptée en
première lecture par votre
assemblée deux amendements d'initiative
commune encore une fois vont être soumis
à à votre assemblée sur cet
article l'objectif est bien que le code
pénal comporte un article unique
regroupant toutes les dispositions
applicable en matière de retrait de
l'autorité parentale d'un contenu
identique aux dispositions figurant dans
le Code civil clarté lisibilité et
impact tel est donc le texte qui se
présente aujourd'hui à vous et que je
l'espère ardemment vous
adopterez car oui nous devons
aujourd'hui envoyer un signal très clair
et rappeler aux parents que donner la
vie à un enfant c'est bien sûr exercer
une autorité pour élever ses enfants
mais c'est aussi et avant tout une
responsabilité or quand on a été
irresponsable la justice doit intervenir
pour protéger l'enfant et limiter les
droits de ses parents agresseurs car le
parent qui mis en cause à forciorie
condamné continue à prendre des
décisions dans la vie quotidienne de
l'enfant alors qu'il a violenté ou violé
c'est faire perdurer la violence c'est
faire perdurer l'emprise
oui nous avons à cœur d'aboutir avec
vous mesdames et messieurs les députés à
une protection renforcée de nos enfants
vous le savez il y a quelques semaines
nous avons lancé une campagne choc pour
éveiller notre société sur le fléau des
violences sexuelles subies par les
enfants l'éan créé l'élan créé pardon
doit s'accompagner de nouveaux outils
pour combattre ce fléo ce texte j'en
suis certaine y contribuera
fortement la justice n'est jamais aussi
grande que lorsqu'elle s'occupe des tout
petits le proclamer une nouvelle fois
haut et fort tel est l'enjeu de nos
débats ce soir nous avons besoin de la
mobilisation de tous et toutes je vous
remercie de votre engagement et de cette
mobilisation pour améliorer et renforcer
la protection de nos enfants merci
beaucoup merci Madame la Ministre la
parole maintenant est à Madame la
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
République madame Isabelle Santiago pour
[Applaudissements]
minutes merci monsieur le
Président Madame madame la ministre
madame la Vice-Présidente de la
commission des lois chers collègues je
suis évidemment ravie de vous retrouver
pour l'examen en 2uxème lecture de cette
proposition de loi visant à mieux
protéger et accompagner les enfants
victimes et COV viictime de violence
intrafamiliale ce texte comme vous le
savez a été adopté à l'unanimité en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
le 9 février dernier lors de la niche du
groupe socialiste cette p PL que j'avais
déposé lors de la mise en place de cette
nouvelle législature est aujourd'hui en
deuxième lecture dans le cadre de la
navette parlementaire et travailler
depuis lors de manière
transpartisane cela nous réunit et
permet des votes à l'unanimité du coup
j'espère que ce soir ce sera aussi
encore le cas c'est l'intérêt général
celui des plus vulnérables et celui des
enfants victimes qui est en jeu à
travers ce texte nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de appel la nécessité de
mieux protéger les enfants des violences
qu'ils subissent au sein de leur
familles qu'ils en soient les victimes
directes ou les covictimes pour mémoire
400000 enfants vivent dans un foyer dans
lequel s'exercent des violences
conjugales et 160000 subissent chaque
année des violences sexuelles en France
nous savons que la mise en sécurité
rapide de l'enfant et un accompagnement
médico-social adapté sont indispensables
pour limiter les effets néga de C
expériences traumatiques notamment mis
en évidence par l'Organisation mondiale
de la santé il faut garantir la sécurité
physique et psychique des enfants il est
vain de soigner un enfant qui côtoit
toujours son agresseur rien n'est plus
créateur d'inégalité dans la
construction de l'enfant que
l'insécurité dans la maison pour cet
enfant la proposition de loi s'attache
donc à agir vite lorsque l'enfant est en
danger pour liiter les relations voir
dans les cas les plus graves rompre le
lien entre l'enfant et le parent violent
ou agresseur dans le cadre de la navette
parlementaire le Sénat a largement
modifié cette proposition de loi lors de
son examen en première lecture et à
limiter les principales avancées qu'elle
prévoyait dans l'article 1 je regrette
qu'il ne soit pas possible à ce stade
d'aboutir à une version qui aurait pu
être conforme mais nous avons en tout
cas de futurs é change avec le Sénat
j'imitai toute ma volonté toute ma
détermination à échanger pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que ce texte au niveau de
son retour vers le Sénat puisse être le
plus
possible non modifié il il il en va en
fait de l'urgence d'adopter ce texte
dans le cadre de la navette
parlementaire et des allers-retours
entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat ce texte
il est attendu les préconisations sont
celles de la
c'est un travail de longue date et
maintenant il est désormais temps qu'il
soit définitivement adopté le mois
dernier en commission des lois nous
avons donc rétabli à l'unanimité la
proposition de loi dans son esprit du
mois de février en première lecture tout
en améliorant aussi et nous avons aussi
gardé des articles qui étaient très
intéressants et qui avaient été portés
par et enrichi par le Sénat donc nous
avons fait un mix pour que le texte soit
le plus équilibré possible tout en
évidemment rétablissant l'article 1 qui
était majeur pour nous ainsi la PPL que
je vous propose aujourd'hui et je
l'espère je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
voter à l'unanimité tout à l'heure en
tout cas je le souhaite d'abord
l'article 1er il prévoit la suspension
de plein droit de l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale et des droits de
visite et d'hébergement dès le stade des
poursuites lorsque le parent est mis en
cause pour des infractions les plus
graves c'est dire un crime sur la
personne de l'autre parent une agression
sexuelle inestueuse ou un crime commis
sur la personne de son enfant dans ce
cas de figure la suspension court
jusqu'à la décision du juge aux affaires
familiales la décision de non lieu du
juge d'instruction ou la décision du
juge pénal la suspension de plein droit
de l'exercice de l'autorité parentale et
des droits de visite et d'hébergement
s'applique aussi en cas de condamnation
pour violence con jugal ayant entraîné
une incapacité totale de travail de plus
de 8 jours lorsque l'enfant a assisté au
fait la mention de la présence de
l'enfant lorsque des violences
conjugales peut-être et qu'il qu'on
précise qu'il qu'il a assisté au fait a
fait débat bien évidemment beaucoup se
sont interpellés sur cette formulation
donc je rappelle et c'est important
parce que je sais que si nous ne sommes
pas très présents en séance à cet
instant du débat il y a du monde aussi
qui nous écoute donc je redis que la
présence des enfants lors des violences
conjugales depuis la loi du 3 août
2018 cette loi prévoit un cadre légal
actuel et qui est réaffirmé en
commission des lois c'est bien une
appsectation large de la notion de
présence de l'enfant lors des violences
qui est précisé dans le droit assisté au
fait ne se limite pas à être un témoin
occulaire des violences dans lequel
l'enfant est témoin des violences qu'il
soit témoins auditif ou oculaire présent
ou non dans la pièce au moment des fait
le fait pour un enfant d'être témoin
direct des conséquences de ces violences
même après qu'elles aient été commises
doit être également pris en compte de
plus les les juridictions s'approprient
de plus en plus la mise en œuvre de ce
statut nous observons une augmentation
même rapide cette circonstance
aggravante aujourd'hui avec la présence
de l'enfant à savoir depuis 2018 dans le
cas que je viens de vous citer et passer
de 43 condamnations en 2018 à
8765 pour l'année 2022 cela montre la
compréhension de cet enjeu dans les
juridictions il faut aller encore plus
loin mais nous ne pouvons que nous
féliciter de cette nette augmentation et
de cette appropriation des évolutions
législatives par ailleurs la suspension
des droits de visite et d'hébergement
est strictement nécessaire la raison
commande de dire très clairement aux
victimes de ces violences je te crois
toute autre attitude est contraire à la
raison le risque n'est pas d'inventer
des victimes il est de laisser passer
sous nos yeux des enfants qui sont
victimes qu'il faut protéger et qui sont
en danger le fait de continuer de
pouvoir rencontrer son enfant y compris
dans des visites mé tisé engendre un
sentiment d'insécurité pour les enfants
tant tant physique que psychique le
besoin de sécurité pour grandir est
primordiale il faut croire et il faut
faire le choix de la sécurité de
l'enfant avant toute chose sa sécurité
affective nécessaire à ses besoins
fondamentaux pour son développement lui
fournir un cercle de sécurité pour lui
permettre de se reconstruire l'article 2
prévoit le retrait
de l'autorité parentale en cas de
condamnation pour des faits de crime
contre l'autre parent l'agression
sexuelle incestuceuse ou crime contre
l'enfant sauf décision contraire
spécialement motivé du juge de plus
plusieurs articles ont été ajoutés dans
cette navette parlementaire comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure l'article 2
B crée un nouveau cas de délégation
forcée de l'autorité parentale en cas de
crime ou d'agression sexuelle
incestueuse par un parent seul titulaire
de l'autorité parentale oui il fallait
penser à tous les cas de figure
l'article 2 terre procède à une
coordination rédactionnelle l'article 2
prévoit qu'un parent ayant fait l'objet
d'un retrait de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale ne peut pas en demander la
restitution avant l'expiration d'un
délai de 6 mois l'article 2 quit très
important prévoit l'exonétion pour le
parent bénéficiaire d'une ordonnance de
protection et d'une autorisation de
dissimuler son domicile de toute
obligation d'informer préalablement
l'autre parent d'un changement de
résidence il faut savoir que depuis des
années où je suis engagé sur la question
des violences faites aux enfants ou les
violences intrafamiliales et la lutte
contre les violences conjugales pour
mieux protéger les femmes cette question
du domicile pour l'enfant était abordée
par toutes les
associations différents article amène à
avoir donc une proportion qui me semble
être très équilibrée et qui répond à
l'ensemble des sujets l'article 4 qui a
été proposé par la délégation au droits
de l'enfant et qui est très importante
concerne un rapport sur le fit
psychologique des enfants à ce stade je
veux vous dire que dans le PLF SS j'ai
déposé un amendement pour que les
enfants puissent être pris en charge
dans le cadre du médico social et de la
possibilité de les accompagner j'espère
que dans le 493 qui a eu lieu il sera
retenu pour accompagner les familles
vous dire qu'il est absolument
nécessaire de faire passer leur
protection au premier plan conformément
aux préconisations de la civice j'ajoute
que nous
avons absolument besoin de poursuivre
l'mission avec la civice qui a fait une
feuille de route pour autant nous aurons
l'occasion madame la ministre d'en
parler demain mais nous avons une
richesse collective avec une parole
apaisée et claire sur
l'indiciible qui parle à chacun de nous
à chacun de nous y compris dans notre
cœur concernant les enfants c'est une
chose précieuse et rare et je vous
invite à poursuivre sur ce chemin pour
les enfants
merci merci Madame la rapporteur j'ouvre
la discussion générale et je donne la
parole aux orateurs des groupes pour 5
minutes chacun premier groupe à
s'exprimer le groupe socialiste avec
Madame Claudia
rouau merci monsieur le
président
madame madame la ministre madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame la
rapporteur chers collègues au préalable
je tiens à souligner l'engagement et la
persévérance de ma collègue socialiste
Isabelle Santiago à l'origine de cette
proposition de loi pour qui le combat en
faveur des enfants a toujours été une
priorité si ce texte est examiné
aujourd'hui c'est aussi qui nous oblige
tous en effet les chiffres en matière de
violence commise contre les enfants au
sein de la fam famille qui en soit les
victimes directes ou les victimes
collatérales sont vertigineux et il est
grand temps que la protection de
l'enfant soit inscrite comme grande
cause nationale ne cessons jamais de le
répéter ce sont 165000 enfants qui
subissent chaque année des violence
sexuelle et 400000 qui vivent dans un
foyer dans lequel s'exerce des violences
conjugales nous savons aussi que les
enfants en situation de handicap sont
plus exposés aux violences sexuelles que
dans 90 % des cas l'agresseur est un
homme et dans 50 % des cas un membre de
la famille toutes ces violences ont des
répercussions très graves sur les
enfants notamment sur leur développement
leur santé leur construction leur
scolarité et leur vie sociale pour bien
grandir un enfant a besoin que le rponde
à ces besoins fondamentaux que sont la
sécurité physique et affective dans
toutes ces situations dans lesquell
l'enfant est en danger il est donc
nécessaire de mettre l'enfant en
sécurité le plus rapidement possible
pour limiter les relations voire dans
les plus cas les plus graves pour rompre
le lien entre l'enfant et le parent
violent ou
agresseur ce texte s'attache à alors
agir vite en introduisant dans la loi
une réactivité salvatrice comme le
réclame de nombreuses associations tout
en respectant le droit des parents ce
texte fait le choix de faire primer
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant il
repose sur deux dispositifs principaux
l'article 1 la suspension de plein droit
de l'exercice de l'autorité parentale et
des droits de visite et d'hébergement
dès le stade des poursuites lorsque le
parent est mis en cause pour les
infractions les plus graves telles que
un crime sur la personne de l'autre
parent une agression sexuelle
incestueuse ou un crime commis sur la
personne de son enfant ou en cas de
condamnation pour violence conjugale
l'article 2 qui renforce l'article 1
avec le RET obligatoire de l'autorité
parentale en cas de condamnation pour
des faits de crimes contre l'autre
parent agression sexuelle incestueuse ou
crime contre l'enfant sauf décision
contraire spécialement motivé du juge
alors que le Sénat avait largement
amoindri ses deux dispositifs en
excluant tout ce qui avait à trait aux
violences conjugales le travail en
commission a permis de revenir à
l'essence même du texte initial car nous
sommes convaincus qu'il est
indispensable de protéger l'enfant de
toute forme et scèes de violence
parentale nous avons conscience que ce
texte initié lors d'une niche n'avait
pas la prétension à répondre à tout
toutes les questions posées sur les
violences intrafamiliales le choix de la
rapporteur s'est donc porté sur
l'urgence à modifier le traitement
judiciaire de l'autorité parentale et
son exercice toutefois il reste beaucoup
à faire notamment sur l'accompagnement
psychosocial et nous appelons le
gouvernement à mettre en place un grand
plan pour aider les enfants victimes et
covictimes de violence intrafamiliale
prévoyant notamment le remboursement des
soins
pédopsychiatriques 544 milliards d'euros
c'est le cooup par de la non protection
des enfants dès le plus jeune âge pour
les systèmes de santé en Europe il est
donc urgent de prendre conscience de cet
enjeu de santé publique et de repérer
les dégâts psychologiques induits par
leur souffrance dès le plus jeune âge je
vous
remercie merci madame la députée pour le
groupe horizon Madame Anne Cécile
violent
merci monsieur le
Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues Victor Hugo écrivait déjà
qu'il n'existe pas de violence sans
lendemain
et il avait
raison parce qu'on estime à 160000 le
nombre d'enfants victimes d'inceste
chaque
année parce que 400000 enfants vivent
aujourd'hui dans un foyer où les
violences conjugales
existe parce que l'on sait que dans 98 %
des cas les enfants sont témoins de ces
violences et donc victimes
eux-même parce que l'on sait hélas que
les violences subies dans l'enfance cré
des souffrances physiques et
psychologiques
durables parce que l'on sait que ces
violences marquent à jamais l'adulte
qu'il devient le temps est venu d'aller
plus loin et de rendre notre arsenal
juridique beaucoup plus protecteur des
enfants
victime toutefois et fort heureusement
notre assemblée n'a pas attendu 2023
pour s'emparer de cette question depuis
2005 de nombreuses lois sont intervenues
en faveur des victimes et ont per permis
la création de nouveaux utils juridiques
et pratiques à disposition des
associations et personnel judiciaire
afin de protéger les enfants et souvent
les femmes notre arsenal législatif
actuel s'est ainsi considérablement
renforcé il le fallait il permet
notamment que l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale soit suspendu de plein droit
lors qu'un des parents est poursuivi
pour un crime commis sur l'autre parent
en outre le juge pénal peut prononcer le
retrait total ou partiel de l'autorité
parentale ou de l'exercice de celle-ci
en cas de condamnation pénale pour un
crime ou un délit commis sur l'enfant ou
l'autre
parent en cas d'inceste ou d'atteinte
volontaire à la vie de l'autre parent
notamment le juge est obligé de se
prononcer sur cette question mais forçit
de constater que ces dispositions
restent encore
insuffisantes je sais l'engagement du
gouvernement sur le sujet et la
mobilisation de Madame Charlotte cobel
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
protection de l'enfance dans la lutte
contre les violences fait aux enfants
qu'ils en soient victimes direct ou
indirect et je tenais à vous en
remercier très
charureusement cette proposition de loi
vise donc à faire un pas de plus vers
une protection efficace des
enfants permettez-moi aussi ici de
saluer l'engagement de la rapporteur ago
sur cette question ainsi que le travail
transpartisan accompli sur ce texte la
proposition de loi que nous examinons a
été adopté à l'unanimité en commission
des lois oui il peut exister des
consensus au sein de cette Assemblée
l'urgence à protéger les enfants en fait
partie et c'est une cause juste sur
laquelle il est urgent
d'agir le travail réalisé à l'Assemblée
nationale a été enrichi par nos
collègues sénateurs notamment par
l'ajout d'une disposition permettant
d'exonérer le parent bénéficiaire d'une
ordonnance de protection de communiquer
à l'autre parent de tout changement de
résidence trop de femmes car il s'agit
dans la plupart des cas des femmes sont
aujourd'hui contraintes d'informer leur
ex-cjoint violent de ce changement de
résidence alors même que celui-ci ne
doit pas pouvoir s'y rendre ni rentrer
en contact avec
elle pour autant nous avons soutenu en
commission les amendements rétablissant
les article 1 2 et 3 tel qu'adopté par
l'Assemblée en première lecture oui nous
pensons qu'il faut élargir les motif de
suspension de plein droit de l'autorité
parentale lorsque nous sommes face à des
poursuites pour agression sexuelle
incestueuse crime commis contre la
personne de l'enfant ou encore face à
des violences ayant entraîné une
incapacité totale de travail de plus de
8 jours avec la circonstance aggravante
que l'enfant est assisté au fait
l'intérêt de l'enfant doit guider
perpétuellement notre action la mise en
place de gardefous supplémentairire
semblait aubien nécessaire av afin
d'éviter toute forme
d'instrumentalisation de ces procédures
que l'on constate malheureusement
parfois lors de séparation
conflictuell aussi le groupe horizon et
apparenté sera toujours déterminé à
accompagner toutes les évolutions
favorable à l'intérêt de l'enfant à sa
protection c'est pourquoi évidemment
nous voterons ce texte avec conviction
je vous remercie pour le groupe
écologiste monsieur Jean-Claude
r merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues lors de l'examen en première
lecture de la proposition de notre
collègue Isabelle Santiago le groupe
écologiste avait rappelé qu'il est de
notre devoir à tous ici présent de
protéger l'intérieur supérieur l'intérêt
supérieur des enfants de cette nation
cela doit être notre boussole à tous et
toutes
toujours avant que notre assemblée
n'entame la nouvelle lecture de cette
proposition de loi il me semble donc
essentiel de réaffirmer que la
protection de l'Intérieur supérieur de
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant est une
exigence
constitutionnelle l'esprit qui anime
cette proposition est sans aucun doute
celui d'une meilleure protection des
enfants et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous la soutenons cette assemblée avait
adopté à l'unanimité en première lecture
une rédaction ambitieuse du texte qui
prenait notamment en compte les
violences volontaires commises sur
l'autres parents pour véritablement
protéger l'enfant même lorsqu'il n'est
pas la victime direct des violences
intrafamiliales bien que le Sénat a
tenté de limiter la portée de ce texte
la commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale a eu la clairevoyance de
rétablir les dispositifs qui avaient été
àoindri vous l'aurez compris chers
collègues notre soutien à cette
proposition de loi est entier et nous
partageons pleinement son objectif ce
texte n'est toutefois qu'un premier pas
nous estimons que nous sommes en mesure
et en devoir d'aller beaucoup plus loin
dans la protection des enfants victimes
et covictimes de violences
intrafamilial face au aux violences
ignobles nous avions voté cette
proposition de loi à l'unanimité en
première lecture j'espère que nous
parviendrons au même résultat
aujourd'hui nous le devons aux millions
de victimes d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
elles nous regardent et attendent de
nous que nous soyons à la hauteur je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
pour le groupe GDR madame Soumia
[Applaudissements]
bouroua merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre madame la rapporteur
chers collègues ces noms sans une
certaine satisfaction que je m'exprime
devant vous aujourd'hui pour la seconde
lecture de la proposition de loi de
notre collègue Isabelle Santiago pour
mieux protéger les enfants victimes de
violence
intrafamiliale après qu'elle ait été
votée à l'unanimité ici même je me
félicite que cette proposition ait pu
poursuivre son chemin parlementaire tant
le problème qu'elle traite constitue
aujourd'hui un enjeu de société
majeure 400000 enfants vivent
aujourd'hui dans un foyer où s'exerc des
violences
intrafamiliales
160000 enfants subissent chaque année
des violences sexuelles en 2019 ces
violences ont augmenté de 14 % en 2020
la hausse s'est poursuivie avec 10
% dans chacun de ces cas il y a une
violence physique ou psychique immédiate
un enfant meurt tous les 5 jours des
suites de maltraitan mais aussi
traumatiqu et des conséquences
saumatiques pour une vie entière les
études et les statistiques sont
glaçantes et sans équivoque 60 % des
enfants témoins de violence souffrent de
stress
posttraumatique et 50 % des victimes de
viol durant leur enfance ont fait une
tentative de suicide il y a donc
nécessité à agir afin de protéger
l'intérêt supérieur des enfants c'est
tout l'intérêt de cette proposition de
loi qui vise à améliorer le traitement
judiciaire des violences intrafamiliales
dont sont victimes les enfants
à ce titre deux évolutions majeures sont
inscrites et visent à palier une
anomalie juridique importante qui
conduit à ce que les auteurs ou auteurs
présumés restent investis de de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale et
n'en sont privé qu'en de très rares
occasions la première vise notamment à
protéger l'enfant dès le début des
procédures judiciaires ainsi lorsque les
faits reprochés concernent un crime les
exercice de l'autorité parentale ainsi
que des droits de visite et
d'hébergement seront suspendus et ce dès
le stade des poursuites la deuxième
évolution majeure du texte c'est le
retrait obligatoire de l'autorité
parentale en cas de condamnation pour
des faits de CRIM contre l'autre parent
agression sexuelle incesttieuse ou
contre ou crime contre l'enfant sauf
décision contraire spécialement motivé
par le juge concernant la première
évolution je me félicite que nous soyons
vu lors de l'examen en commission au
texte qui avait été initialement adopté
ici à l'Assemblée en effet celui-ci
s'avérait plus ambitieux en prévoyant
que la levée immédiate de l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale s'appliquait
lorsque le crime était commis sur
l'enfant mais aussi sur le conjoint
faisant de l'enfant une
covictime un conjoint violent ne peut
être un bon père et je me réjouis que
cette analyse soit de plus en plus
largement partagée la v ilité des
enfants nous commande de de prévoir une
protection stricte sans
concession dans ce cadre je pense que le
testte qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
porte une position équilibrée pour
concilier d'une part la nécessaire
protection des victimes de violence
intrafamiliale et la protection des
enfants et d'autre part la présomption
d'innocence et le droit au juges ce
texte marque donc le début d'un
changement dans notre manière
d'appréhender les violences
intrafamiliales et d'accompagner les
victimes et d'accompagner les victimes
pardon notre groupe s'en félicite et
dans la continuité de son action lors de
la première lecture nous voterons cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
merci Madame merci madame la députée
pour le groupe lotte madame Béatrice des
camp
merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
rapporteur chers collègues en février
dernier lorsque nous avons voté à
l'unanimité ce texte nous avons tous
voulu faire un pas de plus vers la
protection des enfants victime de
violence intrafamiliale ces choses rares
sous cette législature aussi je tiens à
le souligner ce texte aura permis à
notre assemblée de retrouver une
certaine unité et de parler d'une même
voix parce qu'il est urgent d'agir et je
voudrais vous remercier Madame la
rapporteur pour votre travail l'autorité
parentale les violences infligées à
l'enfant dans le noyau familial ce sont
des questions sensibles qui implique une
réponse à la hauteur des
enjeux lorsque la civise la commission
indépendante sur l'incestes et les
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants a
initié ses travaux il a voulu dire à
chacun des 400000 enfant victime je te
crois désormais c'est notre rôle en tant
que législateur de dire à chacun de ces
enfants je te
protège c'est sans grande surprise que
le groupe Liot votera à nouveau pour
cette proposition de loi et ce je tiens
à le dire avec la même détermination
qu'en première lecture la réalité que ce
texte attaque à des difficultés qui ne
sont plus acceptables certaines failles
tant dans le code pénal que dans le Code
civil pénaliser les victimes ou les
placer dans une situation
difficile la priorité en cas de violence
familiale qu'il s'agisse de violence
conjugale ou de viol sexuel contre
l'enfant et de soustraire les enfants à
l'emprise du parent violent à ce titre
cette proposition de loi avec deux
grandes avancées met en place un vrai
bouclier pour défendre ses enfants
d'abord la suspension de plein droit de
l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale suspendre l'exercice de cette
autorité au parents mis en examen ou
condamné pour crime contre le parent ou
pour agression sexuelle ass sur l'enfant
est une
nécessité ça peut paraître évident et
pourtant à l'heure actuelle ce n'est
toujours pas le cas si ce texte entre en
vigueur plus aucun enfant ne devrait
être laissé sous l'autorité d'un parent
ayant commis de tels actes de violence
l'article 1er prévoit aussi une aut un
autre mode plus spécifique de suspension
en cas de violence conjugale en présence
de l'enfant notre groupe avait des
inquiétudes sur ce dernier critère mais
nous avons entendu les précisions que
vous nous avez apporté madame la
rapporteur en commission et encore ici
tout à
l'heure il est essentiel que ce critère
soit apprécié avec souplesse par les
juges pour prendre en compte la présence
même indirecte de l'enfant qui sans être
témoin oculaire des violences conjugales
pourraient en être affecté nous le
rappelons encore une fois les violences
conjugales sont aussi des violences
familiales qui touchent l'enfant je
tiens d'ailleurs à saluer le choix de
maintenir dans le titre de cette loi la
notion d'enfant covictime j'en viens à
l'autre grande avancée de ce texte
pousser les juridictions pénales à
prononcer plus systématiquement le
retrait de l'autorité parentale ou de
son exercice desè qu' cas graves se
présentent face à elle en cas d'inceste
il est nécessaire que le principe soit
celui d'un retrait total de l'autorité
parentale avec ce texte seul une
décision spécialement motivée du juge
pourra en décider autrement c'est une
avancée très attendue un certain
équilibre est maintenu le législateur
guide le juge pénal vers une solution
tout en lui laissant une marge
d'appréciation des situations
individuelles je relève également un
ajout essentiel de notre commission dans
le cas où le juge pénal venait ne pas
retenir le retrait total de l'autorité
il aurait tout de même l'obligation de
se prononcer sur les autres aspects par
exemple prononcer un retrait partiel de
l'autorité ou le retrait de son exercice
le groupe Liot vous l'avez compris
souscrit pleinement à la logique de ce
texte la priorité doit toujours toujours
être la préservation de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant sa sécurité
physique mais aussi ne l'oublions pas sa
sécurité affective c'est pour cette
raison que groupe notre groupe votera à
nouveau pour et espère qu'il sera
rapidement définitivement adopté merci
Madame la
rapporteur merci madame la députée pour
le groupe Renaissance monsieur éic
poulia
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues chaque année près de 160000
enfants sont victimes de violence
sexuelle dans le même espace de temps en
2021 208000 victimes de violence
conjugale ont été recensé don 80 % ay
des enfants derrière ces chiffres il y a
la terrible réalité humaine vécue par
ces centaines de milliers d'enfants
victime de l'inceste et des violences
intrafamiliales ces enfants sont
victimes de ce qu'ils subissent
directement de ce que leur inflige des
membres de Laur propre famille mais
aussi victime de ce qu'il voi de la
violence à laquelle leur environnement
familial les confronte grandissant
auprès d'un parent d'un frère ou d'une
sœur maltraitée C violence sur les
enfant ENF ont des conséquences
ravageuses sur leur développement elles
peuvent se manifester par un stress
post-traumatique par des troubles de
développement du cerveau et du système
nerveux ou par des addictions des traces
lourdes àortter à plus fortes raison
pour un enfant si l'article 3711 du Code
civil évoque la vocation naturelle et
première des parents d'assurer la
protection et l'éducation de leurs
enfants il ne faut pas oublier qu'il
s'agit d'une responsabilité qui leur est
confiée et que l'autorité parentale
accompagnant cette responsabilité doit
s'exercer sans violence physique ou
psychologique lorsqu'il faillissent à
cette responsabilité non seulement
n'assurant plus la protection de
l'enfant mais pire en étant à l'origine
de sa mise en danger le contrat est
rompu et la sécurité physique et
psychologique de l'enfant doit être
assurée et passir avant tout qui
voulons-nous vraiment
protéger la réponse est évidente
l'enfant mais la réalité semble parfois
plus contrastée l'enfant innocent et
victime de T violence ne doit pas subir
en plus de ces mots la latence de la
société même si cela passe par la
restriction de certains droits parentaux
il est nécessaire de le protéger de son
agresseur et de toute violence
supplémentaire physique ou
psychologique depuis 2017 le président
de la République a fait de l'enfance une
priorité de son mandat dont le grenal
des violences de 2019 est une des
nombreuses illustrations notre majorité
s'est engagé à renforcer le déploiement
du bracelet antiraapprochement et du
téléphone grave danger ainsi qu'à donner
la possibilité au juges pénal d'aménager
ou de suspendre l'autorité parentale du
conjoint violent grâce à la loi du 28
décembre
2019 nous avons agi pour permettre la
suspension du droit de visite et
d'hébergement de l'enfant mineur aux
parents violents par la loi du 30
juillet 2020 et pour créer quatre
nouvelles infractions pour protéger les
mineurs des crimes et desalit sexuels en
2021 cette même année faisant suite au
témoignage marquant du Mitou
incest le président de la République a
souhaité la création d'une commission
indépendante chargé d'enquêter sur
l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants la civise a vu le
jour en mars
2021 en 1 an elle a recueilli plus de
16000 témoignages et a élaboré 20
propositions pour mieux prévenir repérer
soigner et traiter judiciairement ces
violen si des mesures importantes ont
été mises en uvre le chemin à parcourir
reste encore long et beaucoup de progrès
sont attendus à
raison la proposition de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui en deè lecture est
attendue car elle contribuera à combler
ses lacunes actuelles de notre droit et
participera à mieux garantir la
protection de l'enfant
le groupe Renaissance partage cette
volonté et salue la convergence qui a pu
être trouvé avec Madame la rapporteur
Isabelle Santiago ainsi qu'avec le
gouvernement tout au long de l'examen de
ce
texte cette proposition s'ajoute aux
engagements pris par le Garde des sa du
P morti et au travail permanent et
inlassable de la secrétaire d'État
chargée de l'enfance Charlotte
cobel ensemble par l'engagement profond
de Madame la rapporteur et du
gouvernement nous avons su trouver
l'équilibre le plus à même de protéger
et accompagner les enfants victimes et
covictimes de violence
intrafamiliale cet équilibre a été
rétabli en commission après les
modifications intervenues au Sénat et
deux amendements identiques déposé en
séance par Madame la rapporteur et notre
groupe contribueront à le parfaire le
groupe Renaissance votera pour cette
proposition de loi ainsi amendé et
espère que ce texte sera une nouvelle
fois adopté à l'unanimité comme ce fut
le cas en première lecture et ces
derniers jours en commission des lois il
sera un exemple de notre capacité à
travailler ensemble à converger pour
protéger nos enfants de pareilles
violence et leur assurer un avenir
meilleur merci merci monsieur le député
pour le groupe rassemblement national
madame Béatrice
roul
Madame le
Ministre madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues dans 8 jours exactement nous
célébrerons la journée internationale
des droits de l'enfant le 20 novembre
marque en effet l'anniversaire de la
signature de la convention intern
nationale des droits de l'enfant adopté
le 20 novembre
1989 par l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies cette convention faut-il
le rappeler avait été précédée par deux
déclarations des droits de l'enfant de
simple portée morale dont la première en
1923 voilà donc un siècle que l'on
cherche à protéger de façon spécifique
les droits de l'enfant et pourtant le
compte n'y est pas un enfant meurt en
France tous les 5 jours des suite de
maltraitance si ce n'est pas bien
davantage comme en témoigne d'autres
association et le docteur Bernard Werny
président de l'ordre national des
médecins qui signalait la mort de deux
enfants par jour en France des suites de
maltraitan parmi ces petites victimes
160000 auraient subi une agression
sexuelle ou un viol incestueux chaque
année dont la majorité aurait été commis
par un proche parent et notamment le
leur et dont 2000 seulement auraiit fait
l'objet de condamnation il fallait donc
agir la loi présentée par Isabelle
Santiago vise précisément mieux protéger
l'enfant victime de violence
intrafamiliale on ne peut plus tolérer
que des enfants risquent de mourir sous
les coups de ceux qui en ont la garde
nous avons eu encore un exemple récent
avec une fillette batue à mort dont les
parents étaient soupçonnés de violence
voilà ce que disait le journal 20
minutes de l'heure le 26 septembre 2023
elle allait fêter son 4e anniversaire
dans quelques jours une enfant âgé de 3
ans a été retrouvé sans vie au domicile
familial le corps de l'enfant présenta
de nombreuses échimoses évoquant les
cours reçus soupçonné de mauvais
traitement le couple inculpé a reconnu
des violences récurrente de l'enfant or
si l'exercice de l'utorité parentale
avait été suspendu dès les premières
violences même de façon provisoire
l'enfant ne serait sans doute pas décédé
c'est en parti l'objet de cette loi qui
apporte deux innovations la première
réside dans la suspension de plein droit
de l'exercice de l'autorité parentale
dès lors qu'un parent est poursuivi pour
crime ou inceste jusqu'à la décision du
juge cette suspension est bien
évidemment déjà prévu dans les codes
civiles actuelle mais elle reste pour
l'instant la liberté du juge dans les
cas de crimes perpétrés sur la mère ou
d'agression sexuelle le père poursuivi
peut ne pas être dépossédé de son droit
de visite et d'hébergement ce qui reste
un compréhensible pour le commun des
mortels lorsqu'une enquête judiciaire
est ouverte disait Marine Le Pen dans
son programme résidentiel c'est bien
parce que des soupçons graves de
maltraitan ont été mis en évidence or il
arrive que le magistrat concerné ne
prenne pas la décision de retirer
l'enfant à ses parents durant cette
période cela a deux conséquences
potentielles un que des cvils existent
se poursuivent
de que des pressions des pressions
soient exercées sur la victime pour pour
qu'elle revienne sur son témoignage
Marine Le Pen a fait de la protection
des mineurs et de la condamnation des
violences physiques une priorité elle
indiquait déjà dans son programme qu'il
fallait mettre à l'abri les enfants
durant le temps des enquêtes de son côté
Édouard Duran juge des enfants prémis
président de la commission indépendante
sur l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
et intrafamiliales indiquer qu'il y a
trop d'aléas dans la décision que peut
prendre un juge tout est dans la loi
certes mais chacun pr sa décision en
fonction des preuves qu'il peut avoir
dans le Assier de sa propre perception
or pendant le temps de la poursuite au
moins l'enfant doit être protégé à tous
les coups à chaque fois et pas seulement
si la certitude de la culpabilité existe
en deuxième lieu cette proposition de
loi vise au retrait total ou partiel
automatique sauf décision spécialement
motivée en cas de crime commis sur la
personne du conjoint ou de l'enfant ou
en cas d'agression sexuelle sur l'enfant
alors sans doute aurait-il fallu aller
encore plus loin en élargissant le champ
d'application du du texte au délit grave
tel que cela était prévu dans sa
rédaction initiale il est de mon point
de vue contraire à l'intérêt de l'enfant
de cantonner cette proposition de loi
aux seules infractions de crime et
d'inceste puisque cela a été dit plus
haut un enfant peut mourir de violence
répétée c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai déposé un amendement en ce sens qui
vise à suspendre l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale également en cas de
poursuite pour violence entraînant une
incapacité totale de plus de 8 jours sur
la personne de l'enfant mais il nen
demeure pas moins que cette proposition
de loi rest une réelle avancée pour la
protection des enfants que je vous
invite à voter il est essentiel et
actuellement plus que jamais de nous
réunir sur des sujets transpartisans et
pour parafer la situation de Gandhi je
terminerai en disant que le degré de
civilisation d'un pays se juge à la
façon dont il TR ses enfants merci
madame la députée pour le groupe LFI
madame Pascale
Martin
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la
rapporteur pour le juge je suis une mère
aliénante folle voulant écarter leur
père j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais
pour protéger mes enfant mais rien de
plus que ce qu' n aurait fait n'importe
quel
parent ces mots ce sont ceux d'Anna dam
Stockholm ces trois enfants ne l'ont pas
vu depuis 3 ans ils vivent avec leur
père quelque part en
Polynésie pourtant leur père fait
l'objet d'une dizaine de signalements
pour violence y compris sexuelle les
signalements des professeurs et des
professionnels de l'azu converge avec
les constats des psychologues qui ont
estimé que les enfants étaient en danger
auprès de
lui il a pourtant été autorisé à passer
les vacances scolaires avec ses enfants
durant l'été 2020 Anna déjà en vacances
avec eux à ce moment-là a tardé à les
lui remettre pour cela elle a été
condamnée pour soustraction d'enfant à 1
an de
prison je le dis devant vous j'aurais
fait comme
elle et je sais que que beaucoup d'entre
vous auraient fait comme elle car notre
premier devoir de parents est de
protéger nos
enfants actuellement l'état du droit
comme le fonctionnement des institutions
ne permettent pas de protéger
efficacement les enfants victimes de
violen intrafamilial le cas d'Anna d'AM
Stockholm est loin d'être isolé trop de
parents violents conservent l'autorité
parentale ainsi que leur droit de visite
et d'hébergement beaucoup de ces enfants
sont alors condamnés à vivre des années
de violence destructrices le nombre
d'enfants concernés est vertigineux
160000 enfants sont victimes de violence
sexuelle chaque année en France 400000
sont victimes ou covictimes de violence
intrafamiliale tout type confondu parmi
eux la majorité ne sont pas protégés y
compris lorsque les violences sont
connues des
institutions le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui a pour objectif de remédier
en partie à ses carance en permettant
d'agir vite lorsqu'un enfant est en
danger en agissant sur la suspension et
le retrait près de l'autorité parentale
et des droits de visite et d'hébergement
il s'agit de pouvoir limiter ou rompre
les relations entre l'enfant et son
parent violent afin de mettre l'enfant
en
sécurité c'est une évolution essentielle
du droit et je remercie l'autrice de ce
texte madame Isabelle Santiago pour son
travail je me félicite que nos députés
de la commission des lois a rétabli
l'esprit du texte de départ qui avait
été vidé de sa substance lors de son
passage au Sénat ce texte et les combats
qui l'accompagnent témoignent d'une
prise de conscience croissante
concernant l'ampleur et la gravité des
violences faites aux enfants cette prise
de conscience n'est pas sans lien avec
la civise qui a réalisé un travail
essentiel depuis bientôt 3 ans et qui
doit pouvoir poursuivre ses missions
depuis des années la civise ainsi que de
nombreux acteurs de la protection de
l'enfance appellent de leur vœux un
changement de paradigme dans la façon
dont les institutions considèrent et
prennent en charge les violences
intrafamiliales
nous sommes actuellement dans un régime
de présomption de culpabilité pour la
personne qui dénonce des violences
commises sur un enfant c'est incroyable
la mère est encore trop fréquemment
accusée de mentir et de manipuler son
enfant pour nuire à son
ex-cagnon quant à la parole de l'enfant
elle-même elle est jugée peu crédible
nous devons passer à un régime de
présomption de crédibilité de la parole
de l'enfant tout simplement car c'est
une condition nécessaire pour que toutes
les victimes puissent être protégé
dès les premiers stades de l'enquête ce
qui prime c'est la protection on parle
ici de violence qui laisse des traces
indélébil on ne peut pas se contenter de
laisser l'enfant avec le parent accusé
de violence et espérer que tout ira bien
on le répète depuis des années un parent
auteur de violence y compris conjugal
n'est pas un bon parent cette
proposition de loi telle que qu'elle
nous parvient aujourd'hui n'est pas
parfaite elle pourrait être plus
protectrice mais elle constitue déjà un
grand pas en avant et mon groupe votera
évidemment pour ce
texte mais je tiens à rappeler que ces
modifications législative devront
s'accompagner d'un plan global de lutte
contre les violences faites aux enfants
quand je parle de plan global j'ai en
tête quelque chose d'un peu plus
ambitieux que ce qu'a mis en place la
secrétaire d'État à l'enfance elle a
lancé dernièrement une campagne
d'information sur les violences sexuel
fait aux enfants c'est très bien mais
quand des enfants ou des adultes verront
cette campagne et décideront de signaler
des faits de violence que se
passera-t-il quel moyen pour la police
la justice l'azu l'éducation nationale
pour traiter correctement ces situations
protéger les enfants et les prendre en
charge seul une hausse des moyens à la
hauteur des besoins permettra la
protection réelle des enfants je vous
remercie merci madame la députée pour le
groupe les républicains monsieur Dino
signeri
merci pour
petit je prendre un peu d'eau parce
que monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le retrait
de l'autorité parentale et dans notre
culture encore difficile à envisager
pourtant cette option est devenue
nécessaire est même indispensable dans
l'éventail des moyens de protection de
l'enfant victime de sa famille en effet
le rapport sauvé publié en octobre 2021
estime que près de 15 % des femmes et
plus de 6 % des hommes majeurs
auraientent été sexuellement agressés
lorsqu'ils étaient mineurs soit environ
10 % de la population globale c'est dire
l'ampleur du phénomène et l'importance
de l'enjeu dont le législateur est
aujourd'hui c'est
concrètement le retrait de l'autorité
parentale prive l'un des parents de
l'ensemble de ses attributions y compris
les plus symboliques comme par exemple
le droit de consentir au mariage de son
enfant ce retrait revient également à
confier exclusivement à l'autre parent
le soin de veiller sur l'enfant et de
prendre les décisions nécessairirees
pour sa santé son éducation et
cetera depuis des décennies les
philosophies des acteurs de la
protection de l'enfant s'opposent sur ce
sujet le législateur doit aujourd'hui
trancher il est indispensable de
sanctionner le parent coupable de
violence extrêmement grave sur l'enfant
et de protéger cette être vulnérable
physiquement en l'éloignant
juridiquement de l'autorité dont il
dépend et qui le détruit à ce titre
madame la rapporteur je veux saluer
votre travail et votre engagement
constant sur ce texte vous êtes
déterminé et vous avez raison de l'être
aujourd'hui avec votre travail nous
allons faire avancer cette cause depuis
quelques années un chemin avait été déjà
engagé et des avancées importantes ont
été obtenues il y a eu la loi du 28
décembre 2019 visant à agir contre les
violences au sein de la famille porté
par mon collègue Aurélien Pradier que je
salue et adopté à l'unanimité à créé un
mécanisme de suspension provisoire de
plein droit de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale et des droits de visite et
d'hébergement du parent poursuivi ou
condamné même non définitivement pour
crime contre l'autre parent il a eu la
loi du 30 juillet 2020 visant à protéger
les victimes de violence conjugale à à
par exemple élargir les cas dans
lesquels les parents peuvent se voir
retirer totalement l'autorité parentale
ou son exercice par une décision
expresse du jugement pénal au cas dans
lesquels des parents ont été condamnés
pour les pour des délit sur d'autres
parents quel lien peut demeurer entre un
enfant et un père qui a commis le pire
envers sa femme c'est là toute la
question veillez à la protection des
enfants à ceux qui n'ont pas leur mots à
dire car ils ne peuvent tout simplement
pas les raconter et notre devoir
collectif c'est donc à nous de les aider
en agissant 400000 enfants qui vivent
dans un foyer dans lequel s'exercent des
violences conjugales
160000 enfants qui subissent chaque
année des violences sexuelles en France
dans 90 % des cas l'agresseur est un
homme et que dans la moitié des cas il
est un membre de la
famille la proposition de loi que nous
examinons renforce les dispositif
juridique existant en suspendant de
plein droit l'autorité parentale du
parent poursuivi pour agression et en le
lui retirant de manière systématique en
cas de condamnation c'est nécessaire
nous lui apportons notre plein soutien
en première lecture les députés et les
sénateurs ont complété et enrichi ce
texte en permettant notamment la
suspension de plein droit dès les
premières poursuites pour agression
sexuelle incestueuse et CRIM commis
contre l'enfant ou contre l'autre parent
l'article 378 du Code civil sera ainsi
écrit efficacement en ce sens en effet
il n'est pas envisageable qu'en cas de
condamnation pour un crime commis sur
son enfant ou sur l'autre parent un
parent puisse conserver l'autorité
parentale en ce sens l'objectif
principale qui doit nous guider
aujourd'hui est celle de la protection
des victimes et de la préservation de
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant c'est
pourquoi je voterai ce texte car il
replace l'enfant victime au cœur du
dispositif judiciaire
coordonner le civil et le pénal est une
priorité pour la protection de l'fant de
l'enfant victime c'est mon intime
conviction le retrait de l'autorité
parentale peut être nécessaire pour
arrêter la reproduction de la violence
familiale au sein des générations
suivante mais il faut en même temps
prévoir l'avenir de sur de cet enfant et
lui offrir une stabilité juridique et
affective sur le long terme je vous
remercie merci de m'avoir
écouté merci merci monsieur le député
merci pour le groupe démocrate madame
Sandrine
[Applaudissements]
jossau
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues
comme le disait nelsand mard nous devons
à nos enfants les citoyens les plus
vulnérables de toute société une vie à
l'abri de la violence et de la peur
or malgré de nombreux textes de
nombreuses mesures de multiples
campagnes de sensibilisation pour
protéger les enfants les violences
intrafamiliales sont toujours présentes
un enfant est tué par l'un de ses
parents tous les 5 jours dans notre
notre
pays ces maltraitances ces infanticides
en constante augmentation sont insoutena
entendons ces cris ces plaintes ces mots
ces souffrances ces traumatismes tenus
sous silence depuis des
années les violences intrafamiliales
sont un fléo dans notre société un fléo
trop souvent tapi dans l'ombre qu'il est
aujourd'hui impossible
d'ignorer pour chacun de ces enfants
nous avons la nécessité la
responsabilité
d'agir grâce à ce texte nous apportons
plus de sécurité dans la vie affective
de
l'enfant ainsi je tiens à féliciter
notre collègue Isabelle Santiago d'avoir
su nous mobiliser de manière
transpartisane face à la gravité de la
situation je remercie également
l'ensemble de mes collègues pour leur
travail qui a permis l'amélioration de
ce texte pour une meilleure protection
de
l'enfance nous démontrons ce soir dans
cet hémicycle notre capacité à nous unir
autour de ce sujet essentiel que sont
les violences intrafamiliales
ensemble bâtissons un avenir où chaque
enfant pourra bénéficier d'un foyer
protecteur pour grandir cet avenir passe
par ce texte soyons- en
fier ce travail transpartisan mené à
l'Assemblée nationale débouche sur un
texte équilibré et nécessaire en tout
point à la protection de l'enfant témoin
et
victime
désormais en cas d'agression sexuelle
incestueuse ou de crime commis par un
parent sur son enfant ou sur l'autre
parent nous pourrons affirmer que
l'autorité parentale et les droit de
visite et d'hébergement pourront être
suspendu et cela dès le déclenchement de
poursuite
judiciaire en adoptant cette loi nous
disons haut et fort que chaque enfant a
le droit de grandir dans un
environnement à l'abri de toute forme de
violence alors
engageons-nous à briser le silence et à
protéger les plus vulnérables c'est une
responsabilité que nous partageons en
tant que
législateur mais surtout en tant qu'être
humain
j'espère que cette proposition de loi
recueilla pour cette seconde lecture
l'unanimité que mérite cette
cause
enfin les mots de la Déclaration des
Droits de l'Enfant de
1959 raisonne aujourd'hui je
cite l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
doit être notre guide il doit être la
considération déterminante de nos
réflexions et de nos
choix le groupe démocrate votera en
faveur de ce texte je vous
remercie merci madame la députée je ne
vois je ne vois pas l'orateur suivant
donc la discussion générale est close
j'en appelle maintenant dans le texte de
la commission les articles de la
proposition de loi sur lesquels les deux
assemblées n'ont pu parvenir à un texte
identique et nous sommes sur l'article
prer avec une série d'amendements le
premier numéro 3 c'est Madame yadan
oui je je vous remercie monsieur le
Président si vous me permettez je vais
défendre les deux amendements que j'ai
j'ai déposé puisquen fait l'exposé des
motifs et le lui même euh ma voix alors
que ce soit très clair et Madame la
rapporteur le le sait parfaitement ma
voix est totalement et très
bienveillante et je la félicite
d'ailleurs pour pour ce cette
proposition de loi elle est
bienveillante mais je tenais simplement
par ma prise de parole à mettre en garde
contre des dérives potentielles qui
peuvent
exister et la protection de l'enfant
passe aussi à mon sens par la protection
contre les instrumentalisations
dont il peut faire l'objet puisqu'il
existe malheureusement et j'en ai pu
faire l'expérience à plusieurs reprises
dans le cadre de mon activité d'avocat
en droit de la famille il existe des cas
où les parents se servent de leurs
enfants un des deux parents se sert de
son enfant comme instrument de vengeance
par rapport à l'autre parent et mon
propos est celui-ci si nous avons une
situation où un des
parents décide pour des raisons qui lui
sont propres parce que il ne supporte
pas l'idée que l'autre parent qu'il
déteste puisse poursuivre des relations
avec son enfant il lui suffit avec cet
article premier grâce à cet article 1er
simplement de demander à ce que l'autre
parent soit poursuivi et de déposer une
plainte pour des faits des malversations
et des violences et à ce moment-là le
lien est coupé définitivement durant le
temps de la procédure qui peut durer
plusieurs mois voir plusieurs années
donc mon propos est simplement de mettre
en garde et c'est la raison pour
laquelle sur mon premier amendement je
je je propose que le mot de plein droit
soit remplacé par peu c'est une
possibilité qui est offerte au juges et
donc de laisser la libre appréciation au
au juge sur ce point et le deuxième
amendement c'est de dire suspension
d'accord du droit
d'ébergement mais pas du droit de visite
laissons la possibilité au moins dans
ces cas-là de d'envisager un droit de
visite dans un lieu neutre dans un lieu
médiatisé d'une association merci à vous
madame la rapporteur voulez-vous nous
donner votre avis sur les deux
amendements défendus présentés par
Madame yadan le 3 et le 4 s'il vous
plaît
oui madame la députée donc nous en avons
d'ailleurs parlé ensemble sur ces deux
amendements la vie sera défavorable donc
bien évidemment nous avons eu cet
échange je partage pas vous avez le
droit bien évidemment de le défendre je
partage pas du tout ce point de vue qui
est au fond sur tous ces sujets très
minoritaires et je souhaiterais surtout
vous rappeler que dans ce texte le
travail transpartisan a amener à à
amener aussi des gardesfous comme on dit
qui sont importants et C cette
suspension court jusqu'à la décision
d'un juge et il y a tout à fait donc
elle ne s'oppose pas évidemment à la
présomption d'innocence car nous
prévoyons ce garde-fou et cette
suspension court donc jusqu'à la
décision d'un juge qui pourra être saisi
le juge aux affaires familiales tel que
saisi par le parent poursuivi soit le
juge d'instruction s'il prononce un non
lieu évidemment dans l'affaire soit le
juge pénal lorsqu'il rend sa décision au
fond donc avis défavorable sur un sujet
que nous nous avons déjà partagé et
échangé et vous savez que sur les
violences conjugales et les violence
faite aux enfants ce que vous évoquez
est extrêmement
minoritaire merci sur les deux
amendements madame la rapporteur votre
avis défavorable sur les deux
amendements le 3 et le 4 oui merci
madame la
ministre nous avons bien sûr une
obligation d'établir un équilibre entre
les principes de présomption d'innocence
et les évidemment les exigences de la
protection de l'enfant aujourd'hui nous
sommes très clairement pas dans cet
équilibre il nous fallait mettre en
place un dispositive qui permettait
certes de d'agir rapidement mais d'aller
vers un juge tout aussi rapidement donc
je suis défavorable aux deux amendements
par ailleurs la la suppression alors
dans dans le premier amendement la
suppression que vous demandez est aussi
euh de faire dans la rédaction de votre
amendement une suspension qui n'est pas
possible pour le parent poursuivi donc
on a vraiment un mécanisme qui enlève
tout de ces de ce texte tout à fait
essentiel je pense que le fait que
intervienne rapidement un juge permettra
de concilier les obligations de
protection où nous ne sommes pas
aujourd'hui à la maille trop d'enfants
restent trop longtemps cont tenu de la
longueur des enquêtes euh dans les mains
entre guillemets et sous l'emprise de
leurs parents je suis défavorable aux
deux amendements merci Madame la
Ministre madame Roulot merci monsieur le
Président alors moi je vous invite à
voter contre cet amendement pour une
bonne raison raison c'est qu'il vide
complètement le texte de sa substance
donc si on veut aujourd'hui faire
avancer le droit des enfants et bien il
faut il faut évidemment ne pas voter cet
amendement parce que cet amendement
revient à l'état actuel du droit
c'est-à-dire que dans l'état actuel du
droit le juge peut tout à fait retirer
l'autorité l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale ou le suspendre mais il il
peut aussi ne pas le faire et en fait
c'est ce que madame yadan qui médiatrice
mais je le suis aussi et et pourtant et
pourtant
euh et pourtant si on faisait droit à
cet amendement et bien ça reviendrait
donc à ce que le juge et encore une fois
la faculté la faculté de faire la
faculté de retirer ou pas l'exercice or
c'est précisément ce qu'on ne veut pas
en cas de crime en cas
d'inceste franchement les familles ne
comprennent pas que ce soit pas
automatique or je rassure tout de suite
ma consœur je lui dis que les craintes
de
de mise en scène en fait et de fraude
d'abord comme vient de le rappeler
madame la rapporteur ce sont des cas
beaucoup moins important que plutôt les
enfants qui devraient être retirés et
qui continuent à aller voir leur père
violent qui les traumatisent et d'autre
part je la rassure parce que soit dans
le cas de la suspension pour l'article
1er soit dans l'autre article c'est en
cas de poursuite on ne poursuit pas
quelqu'un sur rien s'il n'y a rien il
n'y aura pas de poursuite et il n'y aura
donc
pas comment dire de suspension quasi
automatique en plus elle est quasi
automatique elle n'est pas automatique
c'est-à-dire que le juge pourra toujours
par avec une motivation spéciale écarter
ce retrait ou cette suspension et dire
voilà moi dans ce cas je laisse le cet
enfant à son père avec des droits de
visite et cetera parce que j'estime que
donc il n'y a aucun danger à ne pas
voter cet amendement je vous invite à
voter contre parce que sinon vous videz
la loi de toute sa substance merci
madame la
députée il n'y a pas de consur ni de
confrères il n'y a que des collègues sur
le vote de l'amendement numéro 9 je suis
saisi par le groupe du Rassemblement
national d'une demande de scrutin public
et sur le vote de l'article 2 terre par
le groupe socialiste d'une demande de
scrutin public monsieur Terlier
oui merci monsieur le Président on peut
être collègue mais aussi confrère c'est
c'est pas voilà antinomique ça ça pe
nousons pas de titre ici autre que ça pe
ça pe ça peut exister aussi également ça
permet de de rappeler quels étaient les
les anciennes profession de des uns des
uns et des autres bon vous m'autoriserez
à pouvoir le faire dans la liberté qui
est la mienne de m'exprimer à ce micro
monsieur le Président simplement pour
pouvoir
dire merci mes chers collègues monsieur
le Président simplement pour dire à ma
collègue yadan que je partage avec elle
le effectivement le le constat qui a été
le mien aussi également de ce qu'on peut
avoir parmi les des parents voilà un des
parents la tentation d'instrumentaliser
parfois un enfant mais je crois que
comme l'a dit justement madame la
ministre cette problématique là elle a
été clairement identifiée il faut
effectivement peser le respect
évidemment de la présomption d'innocence
mais aussi également de la protection du
droit de l'enfant et je voulais
féliciter la rapporteur santago parce
que je crois qu'on arrive à un équilibre
dans ce texte et puis dire à ma collègue
yadan pour m'opposer à son à son
amendement lui dire que en réalité je
crois que les gardes de fou ils sont
bien présents les gardes de fou ils sont
bien présents ça a été rappelé par la
collègue du rassemblement national quand
on a une autorité de poursuite elle
poursuit sur des indices graves et
concordants que le juge est est amené à
appréhender avant de de poursuivre mais
aussi également un critère qui a été
rajouté qui est celui de l'ITT de plus
de 8 jours c'est-à-dire qu'on va avoir
une personne qui victime qui présente
des des stigmates et qui me de violence
c'est des actes qui sont des actes
concrets appréciés par un juge dans le
casadre de l'autorité de poursuite et
que à ce titre-là à mon sens les les
garanties sont remplies pour qu'on
puisse aboutir à ce dispositif
qui est le bienvenu de de la suspension
de de l'autorité
parentale merci monsieur le député sur
cet amendement numéro 3 on vot à main
levée la reç un avis défavorable
commission gouvernement qui est
pour contre il est rejeté l'amendement
numéro 9 madame Roulot
oui merci monsieur le Président donc je
crois l'avoir dit tout à l'heure en fait
mais je le répète pour ceux qui étaient
pas présents
euh
non non ça n'a rien de non non ça n'a
rien de non non c'est franchement ça n'a
rien de de
vindicatif donc voilà je cherchais en
fait à élargir le texte au aux violences
faites de violence entraînant une étité
de plus de 8 jours sur enfant parce que
je pense que de cantonner le texte à la
uniquement au crimes et aux agressions
sexueles est insuffisant pour protéger
les enfants je l'ai rappelé la petite
Lisa qui est morte de coup en fait
aurait été mieux protégé si on avait
suspendu les droits de de visite et
d'ébergement en cas par exemple de
divorce donc je souhaite en fait que cet
article soit élargi à une autre
infraction parce qu'il faut savoir que
des une des violences ayant entraîné une
ITT de plus de 8 jours se sont déjà des
violences graves et je je crois que j'ai
dit dans mon amendement violence
volontaire donc il n'y a aucun risque là
encore une fois à étendre aux violences
volontaires et ça me semble absolument
nécessaire pour que ces enfants ne
soient pas martyrisés sans que les
adultes ne fassent rien merci Madame la
député madame la
rapporteur alors chers collègues là
aussi nous avons pu échanger autour de
ces questions je vous demanderai en tout
cas c'est un avis défavorable et bien
parce que ce texte euh c'est un
équilibre autour du sujet que nous
traitons et c'est-à-dire on ne peut
difficilement l'élargir par ailleurs il
est évident que la maltraitance faite
des enfants euh le texte ne traite pas
de l'ensemble des sujets on l'avait dit
il aborde certains sujets dans le cadre
de nos travaux par contre vous vous
l'étendez à travers un ITT de 8 jours
l'ancienne vice-présidente à la
protection de l'enfance que j'ai été
pendant de très longues années peut vous
le dire qu'aujourd'hui les juges sur ces
questions-là sont déjà saisis par des
textes de loi assez nombreux qui existe
et en matière de protection de l'enfance
il y a toujours à faire beaucoup mieux
mais en tout cas sur ces points-là c'est
déjà quasi dans le texte et fait dans
les juridictions par contre sur notre
texte qui est aussi un texte
transpartisan sur lequel nous avons
travaillé il est important qu'on soit
dans l'équilibre du texte ce qui touche
à sur la partie des crimes et sur la
partie donc de l'inceste et qui aborde
l'ITT de 8 jours concernant les
violences intrafamilial et l'enfant
covictime voilà l'équilibre du texte et
celui-ci est important de rester y
compris parce qu'après on partira au
Sénat pour essayer là aussi de
convaincre tout le monde donc c'est un
texte sur lequel nous souhaitons rester
sur la base de celui-ci je vous propose
donc défvorable merci madame la
ministre madame la députée deux enjeux
avec cet amendement pour lequel je suis
défavorable aussi d'une part un enjeu de
d'équilibre on vient de le dire on est
sur un texte qui quand même comporte des
enjeux extrêmement importants euh pour
les parents d'une part et donc
évidemment des retrait d'autorité
parentale sur la base de certificats sur
des violences qui peuvent être de nature
parfois psychologique et pas toujours
facile à déterminer les 8 jours d'ITT
c'est pas nécessairement un seuil très
important donc effectivement on a
considéré dans ce dans ce texte qu'il
fallait garder un équilibre je voulais
aussi vous rassurer madame je voulais
aussi vous rassurer madame quand un
enfant aujourd'hui est repéré avec 8
jours d'ittt pardonnez-moi quand un
jours d'ITT la réalité c'est qu'il
existe des mécanismes déjà qui en
matière de provisoire parce que quand il
y a condamnation la loi s'applique he
c'est uniquement dans le temps de
l'enquête quand aujourd'hui on est sur
un enfant qui a 8 jours d'ITT les
mécanismes de protection existe et sont
faciles à mettre en œuvre c'est du
contrôle judiciaire avec l'absence de
contat si vraiment madame dans dans le
cas dont vous parlez en réalité
l'enquête n'avait pas démarré et donc
les mesures provisoires pour protéger
cet enfant n'avaient pas pu être mis en
œuvre en matière quand on constate des
cûts ce qui est plus facile
pardonnez-moi hélas que des agressions
sexuelles les dispositifs de protection
contrôle judiciaire avec interdiction
d'entrer en contact avec les victimes
les ordonnances de placement provisoires
dans des dispositifs de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance existent déjà et sont
extrêmement rapidement mis en œuvre par
par les par les départements et surtout
par le parquet évidemment quand on
arrive trop tard et qu'on a pas démarré
l'enquête c'est les drames qui arrivent
et ça c'est d'autres mécanismes madame
c'est le repérage des violences
évidemment et le signalement des
violences ce n'est pas au moment des
investigations que nous avons des
problèmes pour mettre en protection
c'est le dispositif d'avant le
gouvernement est engagé pour former tous
les professionnels une plateforme
d'écoute sera mis en place très
rapidement pour aussi accompagner les
professionnel c'est d'une autre nature
c'est le repérage des violences une fois
que les violences sont repérées nous
avons tous les outils pour mettre en
protection ce sont des décisions que les
juges prennent régulièrement les
magistrats du parquet aussi pour
protéger les
enfants merci madame la ministre sur le
vote de l'article 1er je suis saisie par
le groupe du Rassemblement national
d'une demande de scrutin public et le
scrutin public sur le de terre a été
retiré sur cet article 9 c'est un
scrutin public je vous laisse revenir à
vos pupitres ilç avis défavorable
commission gouvernement le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est
clos votant 92 exprimé 91 majorité 46
pour 23 contre 68 il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 4 a été présenté les
avis ont été donnés il s'agissait d'un
avis défavorable commission gouvernement
je vous propose de le passer au voix à
mainlevée qui est
pour le 4 qui est contre il est rejeté
nous passons à l'article 1er c'est un
scrutin public vous restez à vos
pupitres et le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos
ah ça va
fonctionner le scrutin est ouvert
jusqu'à ce que ça
fonctionne c'est bon le scrutin est
clos résultat du
scrutin votant 93 86 majorité 44 pour 86
contre 0 il est adopté les articles 2 à
deux terres ne faisant pas l'objet
d'aucun amendement ne faisant l'objet
d'aucun amendement pardon je vais les
mettre au voix successivement l'article
2 à main levée qui est pour contre il
est adopté l'article 2 bis qui est pour
contre il est adopté le de TER a qui est
pour contre il est
adopté je poursuis avec l'article de
terre qui a des amendements le premier
c'éit un une série d'amendements
identiques le premier présenté par la
rapporteur mais avant ceci je vous
indique sur le vote des amendements euh
de identique c'est ça oui et bien je
suis saisi par le groupe du
Rassemblement national d'une demande de
scrutin public et sur l'article 2 quat
saisine par le même groupe les scrutins
sont annoncés madame la rapporteur sur
l'amendement numéro 2
oui ch chers collègues c'est un
amendement
rédactionnel merci Madame la Ministre
favorable é pardon il y a le numéro 6
pardon je laisse monsieur poulier
présenter le numéro 6 monsieur le
Président nous sommes totalement en
phase avec Madame la rapporteur et donc
euh nous alignons sur la rédaction merci
pas de prise de parole c'est un scrutin
publicque sur ces amendements identiques
tout le monde est à son pupitre le
scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos résultat du
scrutin votant 95 expr 94 majorité 48
pour 94 contre 0 il est adopté l'article
2 ter le scrutin public a été retiré
donc je vous propose de voter à main
levée qui est pour contre il est adopté
le texte de la commission l'article 2
quat c'est un scrutin public vous restez
à vos pupitres le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est clos résultat du
scrutin votant 95 expr 94 majorité 48
pour 94 contre 0 il est adopté nous
sommes sur l'article 3 des amendements
qui font l'objet de sous-amendements
donc d'abord l'amendement numéro 1
présenté par Madame la
rapporteur oui chers collègues c'est un
un amendement qui est donc important
rédactionnel mais surtout qui réécrit
pour parfaire les coordinations initiées
entre le code pénal et le code civil et
c'est extrêmement important pour
qu'ensuite quand il sera adopté je
l'espère définitivement et bien que ce
soit évidemment de bonne augure dans les
deux
codes merci Madame la
rapporteur le numéro 7 Monsieur
pouliia Merci Merci monsieur le
Président nous nous sommes d'accord avec
la rédaction aussi également de Monsieur
Madame la rapporteur mais nous sommes
totalement défavorables au
sous-amendement merci monsieur le député
le sous-amendement numéro 14 monsieur
signeri
oui merci monsieur le Président
j'associe mon
collègue Jean-Pierre tê de la Loire afin
de protéger les enfants victimes un
parent auteur co-auteur ou complice de
crime ou d'inceste sur son enfant ne
doit plus avoir l'autorité parentale
sans exception tel est l'objet de ce
sous-amendement merci monsieurer vous
nous présentez le 13 aussi s'il vous
plaît toujours pareil avec Jean-Pierre
tête N
qui s'associe à cet amendement afin de
protéger les frères et sœurs des enfants
victimes le parent auteur co-auteur ou
complice de crime ou d'incè sur l'un de
ces enfants ne doit plus avoir
l'autorité parentale sur aucun d'eux
sans exception tel est l'objet de ce
sousamendement merci Madame la
rapporteur sur l'amendement numéro 7 et
les sous-amendements s'il vous plaît
oui sur l'amendement 14 chers collègues
donc je voudrais rappeler on l'avait
déjà eu ce débat mais je me permets là
de préciser y compris
les décisions donc c'est un amendement
pour lequel je dis défavorable pour
autant on a souvent beaucoup échangé
autour de cette question je rappellerai
que la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a jugé que le prononcé
automatique d'une privation de
l'autorité parentale en cas de
condamnation pénale n'est pas conforme à
l'article 8 de la Convention dès lors
que cette privation ne pouvait être
écartée notamment en fonction de
l'appréciation de l'intérêt de l'enfant
donc en fait c'est pour des raisons de
constitution que nous avons travaillé le
légistique pour parfaire et aboutir à ce
que nous souhaitions au niveau de ce
texte c'est-à-dire amener une décision
quasi automatique mais ne pas l'écrire
sous cette forme pour que ce soit pas un
texte qui soit voté et pas applicable et
antionstitutionnel donc le légistique a
permis de trouver cette solution j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises donc vote je vous amène plutôt
à un vote défavorable pour ma part mais
en tout cas je reste bien évidemment
ouverte au débat mais il est sur le fond
ce sujet euh je réponds monsieur le
Président au au 13 aussi oui sur l'autre
amendement ou donc là aussi défavorable
donc notre PPL évidemment a l'objectif
d'impulser un changement profond dans
les pratiques du juge pénal puisqu'il
aura l'obligation de se prononcer sur
les modalités de l'autorité parentale
dans certaines affaires ce qu'il ne fait
que rarement aujourd'hui donc du coup là
je vous dirais des favorable puisque du
coup dans votre proposition ça ne
concerne pas l'objet en tout cas du du
texte tel que nous nous le prévoyons
merci Madame la rapporteur avant de
donner la parole à madame la ministre je
vous informe sur le vote de l'article 3
je suis saisi par le groupe du
Rassemblement nationalement de secrétire
public et sur l'ensemble de la PPL par
le groupe Renaissance et le groupe
socialiste d'une demande de scrutin
public madame la ministre sur ses
amendements et sous-amendements
simplement vous dire Monsieur le
Président que sur l'amendement précédent
j'aiété effectivement favorable à la
rédaction vous m'avez pas donné la
parole c'est simplement pour vous ne
m'oubliez pas sur les choses évidentes
mais quand même donc simplement vous
dire que je suis parfaitement favorable
à la aux amendements pour bien mettre en
cohérblable pour bien mettre en
cohérence la le Code civil et le code
pénal les deux propositions portées par
Madame la rapporteur et Monsieur Pya
sont tout à fait indispensables pour
qu'il y ait une grande clarté dans
l'application des deux textes Code civil
et code pénal je suis par contte
effectivement défavorable aux deux
sous-amendements je crois qu'il est
extrêmement important de changer les
pratique madame la rapporteur l'a dit
donc que les magistrats systématiquement
se posent la question de l'exercice de
l'autor l'autorité parentale et se
prononce sur les modalités de cet
exercice avec des faits de nature teles
qu'elles sont prévu dans le texte par
contre un texte où il y aurait des
automatismes à mon avis pourrait
d'ailleurs être fragile
constitutionnellement tant évidemment le
lien entre les parents et les enfants
est un lien important qui impose des
décisions de justice pour le couper même
si nous sommes tous d'accord dans
certaines situations couper est
absolument indispensable merci merci
madame la ministre je ne vois pas de
demande de prise de parole nous allons
voter d'abord sur les sous-amendements
qui on reçu un avis défavorable
commission
gouvernement alors sur le 14 qui est
pour contre rejeté le 13 qui est pour
contre rejeté et puis nous avons les
amendements qui on reçu les amendements
1 et 7 qui on reç av favorable si j'ai
bien
compris qui est pour contre ils sont
adoptés et ils entraîne le fait que nous
ne mettions pas au voie l'article 3 donc
nous poursuivons avec l'article 3 bis
que je mets tout de suite au
voix c'est un amendement de rédaction
globale donc le 3
bis qui est pour contre il est adopté le
4 c'est un amendement de rédaction
globale je viens de le dire le 4 qui est
pour contre adopté et sur l'ensemble de
la proposition de loi avant de passer au
vote j'ai des explications de vote d'un
certain nombre de collègue d'orateur par
groupe politique le premier la première
des oratrices étant madame Cécile
untermeayer pour le groupe
socialiste merci euh merci monsieur le
Président merci Madame la rapporteur
merci madame la ministre merci pour ce
travail que vous avez fait je pense que
l'explication de vote elle est sans
surprise nous sommes à la fois très
fiers de du travail qui a été effectué
par notre collègue mais ici vous dire
que c'est peut-être le moment de nous
rappeler aussi le travail d'Édouard
Durand un énorme travail qui a été fait
et finalement on trouve ici une forme
d'aboutissement qui je pense est utile
et et et commande que le travail qu'il
qu'il fait actuellement se poursuive
voilà ce que je voulais dire sur
l'équilibre du texte et bien c'était pas
si facile que ça parce qu'on a quand
même le droitfil de la Constitution qui
nous oblige à peser les termes et
trouver l'équilibre et cela a été
admirablement bien fait je pense que
c'est une grosse avancée c'est un grand
signal qui est envoyé nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup encore à faire en
matière de justice et en particulier sur
les classements sensite madame la
ministre qui sont quand même extrêmement
importants en pourcentage par rapport
aux affaires qui nous préoccupent
aujourd'hui je vous remercie donc le
groupe socialiste avec beaucoup de
fierté et en remerciant aussi finalement
l'adhésion autour du texte votera
évidemment pour ce texte merci madame la
députée pour le groupe horizon madame
Cécile
violent merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre madame la rapporteur
chers collègues alors évidemment ce soir
c'est c'est effectivement une grande
avancée pour la protection de l'enfant
que nous avons
manifestement tous travailler ensemble
et je crois qu'il faut souligner le côté
transpartisan justement de cette
proposition de bravo Madame la
rapporteur de nous avoir permis ce
moment de communion ensemble dans cet
hémicycle ça arrive sur des sujet majeur
absolument donc voilà évidemment que le
groupe Horizon est apparenté votera ce
texte comme je disais tout à l'heure
avec une grande conviction et je crois
que ce chantier qui s'occupe justement
du judiciaire est extrêmement important
mais qu'il y en a un autre qu'il faudra
aborder nécessairement avec beaucoup
d'engagement aussi ce sera celui du soin
de ses enfants et de leur famille merci
beaucoup merci Madame la député pour
Renaissance Éric
Pia merci monsieur le Président tout
d'abord souligner le je suis très
heureux nous sommes très heureux de
d'avoir la réécriture de ce texte à
l'Assemblée nationale tel que nous
l'avions espéré et voulu en première
lecture et souligner également la très
grande qualité du travail que nous av
nous avons pu mener avec Madame la
rapporteur et ainsi que madame la
secrétaire d'État sur le sur le sujet
madame la ministre et Madame la
rapporteur ont été de d' une grande
qualité d'écoute et nous avons pu mener
un travail tout à fait intéressant et
souligner aussi
que ce soir nous pouvons tous être nous
sommes tous heureux dans de pouvoir nous
féliciter d'avoir un groupe qui va faire
avancer très clairement la justice et
qui va faire très clairement avancer la
protection de nos enfants nous sommes
nombreux dans ce groupe à travailler sur
le sujet je pense notamment à notre
collègue Terlier qui a longtemp
travaillé sur la justice des mineurs et
je pense aussi à beaucoup de nos
collègues qui qui avancent sur le sujet
et dire que nous pouvons être fiers tous
ensemble d'avoir collaboré ensemble
collectivement à faire avancer notre
droit dans l'intérêt des
enfants merci pour le groupe
rassemblement national madame Roulot
oui alors nous serons évidemment très
heureux de voter ce texte même si nous
regrettons en fait que l'assemblée n'it
pas voté notre article je rappelle quand
même à madame la ministre qui se
satisfait de signalement fait que je
répète mon histoire le petit Bastien
après neuf signalements a été mise dans
une machine à laver et en est mort donc
oui j'aurait bien voulu qu'il y ait des
suspensions de d'exercice de l'autorité
parentale dès que en fait une
institution avec connaissance de coût
voilà c'est pas grand-chose que je
demandais peut-être que je pourrais euh
faire une autre proposition de loi donc
on aurait voulu que ça aille plus loin
quand même parce que des coups peuvent
entraîner la mort et ça vous le savez
euh donc en tout cas nous allons
effectivement voter cette proposition de
loi dont nous saluons quand même la
belle avancée un pas après l'autre et
nous pouvons remercier Madame le le
rapporteur merci je n'ai pas d'autres
demandes de prise de parole je mets au
voix la proposition de
loi c'est un scrutin public vous êtes à
vos pupitrre le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est clos
[Musique]
votant 111 exprimé 111 majorité 56 pour
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté je donne
la parole à Madame la
rapporteur écoutez c'est tout d'abord
vous remercier remercier l'ensemble des
groupes de cette assemblée c'est un
travail
vraiment à la base que je porte de
longues dates un engagement que je mets
à l'écoute et vraiment en partage avec
tout le monde pour faire avancer le
droit des enfants c'est évidemment
l'intérêt supérieur mais c'est surtout à
vrai dire j'ai pas besoin beaucoup de
vous convaincre je sais qu'il y a une
forte écoute et une avancée qui est
plutôt collective remercier le cabinet
du garde des saau qui évidemment a
beaucoup travaillé avec moi la partie
compris léistique
remercier marine l'administratrice de la
commission des lois qui m'a beaucoup
aidé aussi poursivre qui est excellente
je le
confirme et en tout cas remercier
l'ensemble des personnes qui ont
travaillé avec moi mes collaborateurs
bien évidemment euh évidemment vous dire
aussi combien je remercie mon groupe à
la base puisque ce texte a été initié
tout d'abord certes par moi-même signé
par mes collègues mais aussi dans la
niche en première présent tion et voté à
l'unanimité lors de la niche socialiste
donc je mesure les pas qui avancent les
briques qui s'ajoute je voudrais dire et
je souhaite vraiment et c'est important
pour moi que collectivement on dise à
nos amis et collègues sénateur et je
crois qu'on a des connaissances dans
tous les groupes qui sont au Sénat on a
besoin d'une lecture au Sénat et rapide
parce que je crois que l'intérêt
supérieur des enfants c'est que ce texte
soit adopté et si c'est possible sur un
vote conforme et je crois que en tout
cas c'est ce qu'attendent les enfants
c'est l'urgence de ce texte de mieux les
accompagner donc je vous remercie tous
et encore bravo pour tout le travail
qu'on a mené mais collectivement et
ensemble madame la secrétaire d'État
madame la ministre je vous remercie
aussi de votre écoute sur de nombreux
sujets que nous portons ensemble merci
Madame la rapporteur madame la
[Applaudissements]
ministre évidemment toujours très honoré
d'être dans cet hémicycle avec
l'adoption de textes transpartisans qui
sont au service et de la protection de
nos enfants voilà évidemment une pierre
tout à fait indispensable dans le
dispositif global qui est constitué de
plein de petites pierres il y a le
numérique il y a la protection des des
violences il a évidemment les textes qui
ont été pris par le Gard des saau et par
vous dans le précédent quinquena il y a
le travail de la Chancellerie il y a le
nouvel office du ministre de l'Intérieur
il y a notre engagement collectif cette
priorité placée par la première ministre
et par le Président de la République
c'est un combat que nous devons tous
porter je vous remercie une nouvelle
fois de le porter à avec moi parce que
c'est mon combat personnel il faut
évidemment que ces chiffres que j'ai
encore une fois répété connaissent une
inflexion rapide forte et l'engagement
de l'Assemblée nationale je suis sûr
doit pouvoir contribuer à toucher tous
les adultes de ce pays nous ne devons
plus accepter quoi que ce soit et nous
devons être vigilants oui madame la
déput ut nous avons trop de signalements
qui ne n'entraînent pas une réaction
suffisamment importante de de des
autorités mais nous avons aujourd'hui
aussi mis des moyens le ministre de
l'Intérieur a mis des moyens le ministre
de la Justice a mis des moyens qui
peuvent nous laisser espérer que ces
réponses s'accélèrent et que nous
mettions en protection grâce à votre
texte beaucoup d'enfants qui aujourd'hui
avaient peur de se retrouver sous
l'autorité de leur parents vont pouvoir
trouver une certaine sérénité je dis
bien une certaine parce que évidemment
c'est un tout petit bout du chemin pour
les remettre dans la reconstruction de
leur vie d'enfant et leur vie d'adulte
encore un immense merci pour ce vote
transpartisant merci beaucoup